-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night." We hope
you're doing well tonight.
Now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
Politico published an article
yesterday titled
"Biden Won't Directly Address
the Age Issue."
Well, that's part
of the age issue.
Guys that age don't directly
address anything.
If you ask your grandpa
what time it is,
he'll say something like,
"Come on out back with me, kid.
We're gonna make a sundial."
[ Laughter ]
President Biden met today
with a group of CEOs
to discuss the economy.
"Look, we're all strapped
for cash," they said,
from space.
[ Laughter ]
After federal prosecutions filed
additional counts --
federal prosecutors filed
additional counts against him,
George Santos told reporters
yesterday, quote,
"I'm pretty much denying
every last bit of charges."
"Pretty much"?
[ Laughter ]
What kind of defense
is "pretty much"?
"The defendant's been charged
with armed robbery
and two counts of murder one.
How do you plead?"
"Like 95% not guilty,
Your Honor."
[ Laughter ]
"Like, rounding up,
totally not guilty."
[ Laughter ]
During a gathering this week
of Republican donors
and influencers,
Utah Senator Mitt Romney
said, quote,
"Our party has
multiple personality disorder."
Though Romney's trying
to offset that
by not having one at all.
[ Laughter ]
Russian President Vladimir Putin
traveled today to Kyrgyzstan
on his first
foreign visit of the year,
where the leadership
begged Putin to send over
some much needed vowels.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
That's how dialed we are in
to the geopolitical situations
that are happening.
You know what?
The good news is,
if Putin watched,
I think
he kind of liked that joke.
You know, I bet when Putin
watches the late night shows
right now
and he sees his picture come up,
he's like,
[Russian accent] "Here we go."
[ Laughter ]
"Okay, let me guess. They're
gonna dump on old Vlad again."
[Normal voice] I bet he watched
that one, he was like...
[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
[Russian accent]
I just had a good laugh.
Don't push Ivan out the window.
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice]
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
hosted an event
at the White House yesterday
honoring teenage girls
and young women.
Smart move to plan it
while Matt Gaetz is busy
with the speaker vote.
[ Laughter and groans ]
[Russian accent] Well, I don't
like that. Matt is good friend.
[ Laughter ]
It's about Ivan.
Yes, I've changed my mind.
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice]
A teenager in Australia
recently set
a Guinness World Record
after he solved
a Rubik's Cube
in under 12 seconds
while blindfolded.
Wow! How did he have
such nimble hands?
Ohh, okay.
[ Laughter and groans ]
[ Laughter ]
There's a lot of reasons
that joke doesn't work.
That's why --
That's why I like it.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview,
actress Jada Pinkett Smith said
that she and actor Will Smith
have been separated since 2016.
And when he heard that,
Chris Rock slapped himself.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, according
to a new study,
female frogs may pretend
they are dead
to avoid mating with male frogs.
Boy, you know the sex is bad
when you'd rather be dissected
by eighth graders.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!
We are off and running,
as they say.